oh it's coming back in more indoor mask
mandates
in one of the biggest cities in the
country you should know what's happening
here
fox's trace gallagher does he's got the
story for us now hi trace
hey tucker if you're looking for a case
study and how to generate confusion the
l.a county health department just gave
us a step-by-step
guide here's the reasoning coronavirus
cases in los angeles county are now
above 1 000 for the seventh straight day
therefore everyone including those fully
vaccinated once again have to wear a
mask indoors now federal guidance is the
exact opposite
cdc director rachelle wolenski says
vaccinated people are safe from the
delta variant of the coronavirus
and do not have to wear masks indoors in
fact
even when the l.a county health
department was issuing the mandate today
it was simultaneously making its case
and
undermining its case for example the
county says hospitalizations are now at
452. that's
up from last week but the county goes on
to say quoting here
to date we have not had a patient
admitted to a hospital
who has been fully vaccinated with
either the j j
pfizer or moderna vaccine every single
patient that we've admitted for covet
is not yet fully vaccinated the question
is if the fully vaccinated or not
getting sick why do they have to wear
masks the county says the answer is that
businesses
have no way of verifying who has and has
not been vaccinated
so it's now one size fits all and we
should note finally
the county health director is not ruling
out the implementation of stricter
mandates
including more shutdowns stay tuned
tucker l.a county
appears to be on a roll you can power to
politicians good luck getting it back
chris gallagher thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else